die Schuld von Alec Baldwin ja er hat
die tragischen Todesschüsse abgegeben
auf seine kamera-frau einen tragischer
Unfall ja aber das Polizeiprotokoll legt
das Chaos am Filmset jetzt offen und es
ist auch Baldwins Chaos denn er war ja
auch der Produzent des Films vor allem
in Sachen Sicherheit ging es chaotisch
am Set zu hier sehen wir das
Polizeiprotokoll besonders krass darin
die Zeugenaussagen des zweiten
Kameramanns Russell weed
denn darin heißt es hier in dem
protokollweed weiß ich nicht sicher
warum die Waffe abgefeuert wurde hier
sehen wir den Auszug und hörte nur einen
lauten Knall und er sagte auch aus
nachdem die Waffe abgefeuert worden war
erinnerte er sich dass Joel blutete der
Regisseur und Halina sagte dass sie ihre
Beine nicht mehr spüre read gab an dass
sich Sanitäter um ihre blutende
Verletzung kümmerten als sie auf dem
Boden des Gebäudes lag das ganze fand ja
am Drehort in einer Kirche statt ja und
über diese Details aus den
polizeiprotokollen und über das was
möglicherweise Alec Baldwin noch
erwarten muss möglicherweise auch
juristisch darüber wollen wir sprechen
jetzt mit unserem us-korrespondenten mit
Herbert Bauer Nebel hallo Herbert
hallo Grüße nach Berlin täusch der
Eindruck oder schnürt sich so ein
bisschen das alles zu rund um Alec
Baldwin muss er möglicherweise eben
damit rechnen dass er ja auch dafür
belangt wird dass er eben doch Schuld
trägt und er nicht sozusagen derjenige
ist der das Tragische Opfer auch dieser
Geschichte
festzustellen ist hier in Santa Fe
natürlich zum einen dass sich die
Polizei Ermittlungen hier intensivieren
ich selbst habe bei der Einfahrt zu
dieser Bonanza Creed Ranch diesen
Gelände wo es zum tödlichen Schuss
gekommen ist zwei Fahrzeuge gesehen bin
in fünf Minuten die da hineingefahren
sind man sieht hier das das Sheriff
Department dass die die Polizei hier mit
Hochdruck ermittelt und natürlich gibt
es immer wieder diese neuen Details die
natürlich für Alec Baldwin ein großes
Problem werden könnten besonders auch
die Leute die eher offensichtlich
angestellt hat oder zugelassen hat dass
sie angestellt wurden darunter eben der
Regieassistent es wurde jetzt bekannt
dass die im Jahr 2019 von einem anderen
Film gefeuert wurde hätte sich dort
aufgeführt barbarisch was gegenüber vom
Mitarbeitern und noch wichtiger ist
hätte sich dort einen Schuss gelöst aus
einer Requisiten war für eigentlich sehr
ähnlich dem Vorfall der jetzt die ganze
Welt erschüttert hat das ist die eine
Entwicklung die andere ist dass es aus
Ermittlerkreisen heißt das am Standort
am Filmset Patronen gefunden wurden die
außerhalb der Packung waren die nicht
verpackt waren darunter eben scharfe
Munition und Platzpatronen das alles
durcheinander das zeigt eben welche
chaotische Zustände hier geherrscht
haben am Filmset
immer wieder wird jetzt auch Baldwins
Haltung zum Thema Waffen thematisiert
wie genau ist er seine Haltung
Alex
muss man sagen für einen liberalen doch
grundsätzlich moderatere Haltung er ist
er gesteht den Menschen ein dass sie
Waffen haben dürfen allerdings er
forderte mehrmals dass es dafür einfach
strengere Regeln geben müssen beim Kauf
von Waffen man Gebrauch von Waffen er
sagt es müsste hier strengere
Lizenzierungen geben eben ein
Kontrollmechanismen die verhindern dass
hier Missbrauch betrieben wird er hat
das verglichen etwa mit Medikamenten die
man sich ja auch in einer Apotheke holen
muss die ein Arzt verschreiben muss
jetzt natürlich ist die Ironie klar dass
Alec Baldwin selbst der Produzent war
einer Filmproduktion wo wirklich
chaotische und schockierende Zustände
geherrscht haben und sehen hier gerade
in Amerika du sprichst entschuldige aber
wir sehen hier gerade ein älteres Zitat
eingeblendet von Alec Baldwin im
Gespräch damals mit Pierce moring bei
CNN hat er diesen Satz hier gesagt oder
diese Sätze gesagt genau das was du
gerade mit deinen Worten beschrieben
hast der steht den Leuten schon zu dass
sie Waffen besitzen dürfen aber er
fordert da eben in diesem cnn-gespräch
eindeutig härtere Kontrollmechanismen
also der letzte Satz ist der wichtige
sollte gründlich geprüft werden ob
jemand eine Waffe haben darf und da
machen sich eben jetzt viele drüber auch
lustig unter anderem Donald Trump Junior
der sagt Mensch ja also so ist es mit
der Lack bald wenn auf der einen Seite
fordert der Schärfe Kontrollen oder auf
der anderen Seite dann solch ein Chaos
bei ihm am Set
ja natürlich ja Donald Trump Junior der
Sohn des ehemaligen Präsidenten ist
praktisch an Fürsprecher der Waffen
Befürworter in Amerika die jetzt
natürlich das ist fast ein gefundenes
Fressen für diese Waffen Befürworter
auch wenn das ein tragischer Vorfall ist
denn sie können jetzt sagen es ist hier
eine Heuchelei eine Doppelmoral
festzustellen bei Alec Baldwin der sich
hier als großer Waffen beschränker
aufspielt der strengere Regeln und
Kontrollen fordert und gleichzeitig eben
wie gesagt zulässt das auf seinem
eigenen Filmset solche Zustände
herrschen und da Donald Trump Junior hat
hier sogar ein T-Shirt jetzt verkaufen
lassen mit den berühmten Spruch ganz
don't people people do also übersetzt
Menschen Waffen töten nicht Menschen
töten und das hat er umformuliert auf
Waffen töten nicht Alec Baldwin tötet
Menschen und das natürlich halten viele
für eine Geschmacklosigkeit aber auf der
anderen Seite ist gibt es Menschen die
das eben gerechtfertigt finden als
gerechtfertige Kritik man darf auch
nicht vergessen dass Alec natürlich ein
bisschen ein Feind der trump-familie ist
denn er hat auf der in der TV-Show
Saturday Night Live eben Donald Trump
jahrelang verkörpert und so gesehen ist
das natürlich eine Fehde zwischen den
beiden und auch ein Ausdruck wie
polarisiert Amerika ist diese diese
Spaltung der Nation ist auch hier nach
dieser Tragödie sichtbar in Amerika
natürlich ist es geschmacklos muss man
sagen Herbert Patricia aber es zeigt
eben dass der Fokus immer stärker auf
Alec Baldwin Gerät
Herbert vielen herzlichen Dank für deine
Einschätzung soweit dir ist es ja auch
gelungen mit einem absoluten Experten
auf diesem Gebiet zu sprechen denn alle
Welt fragt sich was könnte Alec Baldwin
jetzt drohen wie geht es jetzt für ihn
weiter wir haben gerade aufgezeichnet
man kann durchaus sagen man kann ihm
durchaus unterstellen dass eine gewisse
Mitschuld vorliegt an diesen Vorgängen
zumindest ist er es Produzent des Films
für viele Dinge was die am Set passieren
Menschen die er einstellt verantwortlich
und darüber hat unser Kollege Herbert
Bauer ne haben wir eben gerade gesehen
haben mit einem der berühmtesten
us-promi-anwälte gesprochen da schon mal
rein
sie haben erwähnt dass Alec Baldwin
strafrechtliche Konsequenzen erwarten
könnten und er auch strafrechtliche
Implikationen befürchten muss worauf
begründen Sie diese Annahme
es muss keine Absicht sein aber er hat
jemand anderen in Gefahr gebracht es gab
viele Beschwerden über Sicherheitslücken
von der crewen Bezug auf Waffen am Set
er hätte wissen sollen dass ein gewisses
Risiko besteht zweitens hätte er wissen
müssen dass es risikoreiche Handlungen
mit scharfem Waffen gab er hat erst
offensichtlich eine unerfahrene
waffenmeisterin engagiert es kommt noch
hinzu dass er um Geld zu sparen ein Team
gebucht hat das nicht abgestimmt war
normalerweise nutzt man aufeinander
abgestimmte Filmcrews die die
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen kennen und
einhalten um Geld zu sparen nutzte er
ein Team das nicht aufeinander
abgestimmt war es wundert mich warum
jemand eine unerfahrene Crew benutzt um
Geld zu sparen ich denke er hat eine
gewisse Mitschuld auch wenn er nicht
gewusst hat dass eine echte Kugel in der
Kammer war hätte er wissen müssen dass
es ein gewisses Risiko birgt davor mit
echter Munition zu schießen
was könnten mögliche Strafen sein
fahrlässige Tötung fahrlässige Tötung
bedeutet dass du dich selbst so
fahrlässig verhältst dass jemand bei
deiner Handlung sterben könnte
erklären Sie uns einmal wie die
juristischen Schritte sind nachdem die
Ermittlung aufgenommen wurden vom
Department Santa Fe wie geht es jetzt
weiter
Ermittler untersuchen den Fall mit dem
Staatsanwalt und er entscheidet ob er
dem Haftrichter vorgeführt wird denken
Sie daran dass es auch politische Gründe
geben könnte ihn nicht zu verurteilen er
ist ein großer Name zweitens versucht
die Filmindustrie in New Mexico gerade
Fuß zu fassen und sie wollen die Leute
nicht verunsichern es würde einen großen
Druck auf den Staatsanwalt geben er ist
der Produzent es ist sein Job alles zu
überwachen während des Filmes und
offensichtlich hat er das nicht gemacht
welche anderen Schritte könnten noch
eingeleitet werden eine zivilrechtliche
Klage geht es hier nur ums Geld
nein offensichtlich nicht denn sie ist
tot dann geht es nicht mehr nur ums Geld
es gibt keine Möglichkeit ein
zivilrechtliches Verfahren einzuleiten
er ist der Produzent es ist sein Job er
braucht nicht die gleichen
Qualifikationen wie seine Mitarbeiter
ich bin mir sicher dass er sich keine
Gedanken machen muss zivilrechtlich
bestraft zu werden da er Versicherung
hat aber selbst seine Versicherung wird
ihn zu einem Vergleich zwingen wollen es
muss sich geeinigt werden es ist eine
furchtbare Verkettung von Umständen sie
hätten wissen müssen dass sie einen
höheren Sicherheitsstandard haben
sollten
Bodys your take was war für Sie das
schockierendste Detail der Ermittlung
bisher finding
ich ziehe hier noch keine Schlüssel das
einzig schockierende ist dass alles so
geheim gehalten wird das ist aber auch
nicht wirklich schockierend das ist ein
so ernst zu nehmendes Verbrechen ein so
ernst zu nehmender Vorfall und es sind
so viele Prominente Menschen involviert
sie wollen das also so lautlos wie
möglich austragen bis sie eine
Entscheidung fällen
das also sagt Edward Haze
us-promi-anwalts der schon Robert de
Niro verteidigt hat und viele andere
mehr in Hollywood und er schätzt ein
dass es durchaus Konsequenzen geben
könnte für Alec Baldwin